hello Toronto what's up guys man it's
great to be here with you
what an amazing what a welcoming what a
thriving City
somebody told me recently it's actually
considered one of the most diverse
cities in the world which i think is
something to be proud of man like people
coming together people converging people
getting along I mean this is really
really inspiring to be here I think we
could we could use a little bit of that
inclusion back in the u.s. at the moment
so yeah honestly it's a thrill to be
here with you guys my whole experience
in Canada so far Vancouver was
magnificent Kelowna was amazing and it's
great to be here with you guys now so
yeah I'm Jason nice to meet you guys
and I hosted a show called brain games
on the National Geographic Channel for a
couple years and that show was all about
our perceptions and our misperceptions
of reality and as it turns out reality
is coupled to perception as Joseph
Campbell used to say reality is just a
word and a word that you shouldn't use
without quotation marks around it and
what I mean by that is that often the
lenses through which we see the world
cloud our perception of the world right
we see with our lenses we see through
our lenses but we often don't see the
lenses themselves and I think a lot of
the afflictions of anxiety and
depression that we're seeing today these
epidemic levels of existential angst
have a lot to do with the story that
would tell ourselves about ourselves a
friend of mine who has a youtube channel
called the nerd rider who I admire very
much was once asked about the nature of
a personal crisis and he said basically
a personal crisis begins when the story
you tell yourself about yourself is no
longer convincing because we live inside
our stories we are autobiographical
beings
have this running narrative and this
story provides the the maps of meaning
that govern our lives these stories tell
us what to do and how to do it you've
probably read Joseph Campbell's work the
hero with a thousand faces which
deconstructs how all mythologies all
stories all effective cathartic
transformative stories across time share
the same patterns share the same motif
they all involve answering the call they
all involve experiencing a little bit of
a fire in that belly right some
discomfort some angst that pulls you
towards the unknown that pulls you
towards an adventure that pulls you
towards your fears that pulls you
towards the dragon right you know the
cave you fear holds the treasure you
seek right everything you want is on the
other side of fear I mean we've all read
the bumper stickers we've all heard it a
thousand times but there is a lot of
truth to these mythologies there is a
lot of truth to these patterns to these
maps of meaning and I think we can learn
from applying those insights from
applying those patterns in our lives as
Isaiah Berlin famously said to
understand is to perceive patterns to
understand is to connect the dots but
you also my friends have to at least
subjectively connect the dots in a way
that serves you right somebody today at
lunch was talking to me about the fact
that their favorite word is Pro Noah
now Pro Noah is the antidote to paranoia
so if you're connecting the dots in a
way that makes it seem like the world is
against you you're being paranoid
if you're connecting the dots in a way
that tells you the world is serving you
then you're Pro noid instead of paranoia
I thought that was a great phrase but
again where does this start for me and I
grew up in South America I grew up in
Venezuela and oh yeah a couple of
minnesota's in the audience that's nice
I was lucky I grew up in a bilingual
multicultural environment I studied an
American school and my household was one
that was largely secular but emphasized
kindness and creativity
my mother always said that the the way
in which you deal with your angst your
pain your grief your sorrow your
frustration is through artistic
creativity through expressing your
creativity and so I guess it was
inevitable for me to eventually fall in
love with the video camera because it
provided a means to artfully capture
and/or articulate angst and turn it into
an active work project the psychologist
Ernest Becker who wrote a Pulitzer
prize-winning book called the denial of
death which is a marvelous book that I
recommend to every body he says that the
difference between the neurotic and the
artist is precisely the fact that the
neurotic cannot create and so he chokes
on his intro versions see both of them
are highly sensitive both of them are
acutely aware of the human condition
they both bite off more than they can
chew
they both take in the world with
remarkable intensity but the neurotic is
overwhelmed by that intensity and again
lives inside of these cul-de-sacs and
error messages and self-doubt and
crippling self-loathing and all that
jazz eventually having probably to
medicate himself to get through it the
artist feels the same angst but turns it
into an active work project so what is
the solution what is the one of the most
effective responses to the human Kanaan
drum is to figure out something creative
that you can do with that fire in your
belly right find out something creative
that you can do with that existential
angst and by the way when stripped of
all these stories what is this
existential angst I think it was
summarized most effectively in a
documentary called flight from death
about the ideas of Ernest Becker and the
documentary begins with the following
nurit narration he says to have emerged
from nothing right because we literally
emerged from nothing to have a name
conscious
this of self deep inner feeling an
excruciating inner yearning for life and
self-expression
and with all this yet to die all right
human beings we find ourselves uniquely
in quite the predicament because we have
the mental capacity to ponder the
infinite seemingly capable of anything
yet we're housed in these heart pumping
breath gasping decaying bodies so
they're simultaneously gods and worms
it's up this guide is professor
Sheldon Solomon who studies terror
management theory the ways in which we
respond to the anxiety of being mortal
beings says it even more crudely the
explicit awareness that you're a
breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die and ultimately no more
significant than a lizard or a potato is
not especially uplifting this is the
human cannon
back when Sigmund Freud's ideas about
neurosis were really popular everything
could be reduced down to sexual
repression right we were hysterical and
anxious and nervous and neurotic because
we weren't getting off in bed right that
was in a nutshell Freud but Ernest
Becker I think is even more interesting
and more broad he says yeah that's
that's one aspect of it but the source
of our faint disquiet the source of our
existential malaise is ultimately the
unbearable awareness of being mortal and
knowing it
see we're the only species that can
contemplate its own mortality other
animals respond to a threat but as soon
as the threat is not there anymore they
go back into the blissful now
whereas we tend to lose sleep over the
fact that one day a decade from now a
century or maybe half a century twenty
five years from now we'll get old will
wither away and we will die right and so
that anxiety is something we have to do
something with in fact this guy goes as
far as saying that the entire human
character structure the whole identity
symbolic system that we've come up with
right our sense of self the social
constructs that we invest ourselves in
the mythological motifs that provide
maps and meaning for our lives these
these virtual realities these these
cultural operating systems are necessary
illusions in other words they are
necessary fictions they are fictions
that are required for our mental health
that without these constructs the only
response to the human condition is full
and open psychosis Ernest Becker says
schizophrenics are suffering from the
truth but here's the thing the dream is
real when you're in it these virtual
realities are rendered real the minute
that we suspend disbelief and invest
ourselves in them in other words these
maps of meaning only require consensus
and commitment to become real it's only
when there's cracks in our maps of
meaning that the problems arise and so
the beginning of a personal crisis then
becomes a chance to tell a better
story that serves not just us
but our fellow humans right if there's
one thing that we can do with our lives
to render it significant in the face of
death right Carl Sagan's mote of dust
suspended in a sunbeam which is what
earth ultimately can be reduced to from
the vantage point of space then how can
we craft narratives and stories right
maps of meaning
that direct our lives in ways that can
serve our common humanity with empathy
compassion and love there should be
nothing else right now honest earnest
Becker well you guys are sweet Ernest
Becker has mapped responses to the human
cannon room throughout history now the
initial solution was religion in its
conventional form a social technology
that provided these sort of comforting
blanketing stories these maps of meaning
don't worry don't worry if you're a good
person if you have a moral compass if
you help thy excetera etc etc you'll
live forever in the kingdom of God and
death will not rob you of your glory
right great great story I'm envious in a
loving way of those that are faithful
but it doesn't doesn't do it for me I
asked too many questions I look for too
much evidence and in the end doesn't
doesn't do it for me plus when applied
by human beings we tend to corrupt and
distort and misinterpret the elegant
allegories of religion the beautiful
metaphors and life lessons by taking
them literally and before we know it
using them as means of social control
opium of the masses etc so we know that
we do a piss-poor job of applying a lot
of the insights from religion the other
way that we've responded to our
situation in the past is through the
romantic solution to the problem of
death the romantic solution to the
problem of death that's a fun one to
dive into from time to time that's when
we deify our friends and lovers mostly
our lovers she's like the wind she's my
salvation
she is the Song of Songs when I look
into the iris of a lovers I I am having
my way with something larger and grander
than myself by wrapping up against
perfection itself we are absolved of our
mortality and we feel and/or become
infinite it feels great but no
relationship can bear the burden of
godhood no card gods will avenge
reveal their clay feet and then once we
see these cracks those cracks are like
mirrors broken mirrors that reveal our
own flaws and cracks and fears back to
us we then deflate the love object and
find ourselves back in our own nodding
resignation so loves tough I'm all about
it I'm a total romantic I've fallen in
and out of love a million times but in
the end it's probably the third solution
to the problem of death that is the most
effective one and that's the one that I
was talking about before to give
ourselves to something grander and
larger to come up with a story to come
up with a creative response to the human
condition a creative project that we can
use to impregnate our lives with meaning
and significant this is ultimately what
it's all about right and so I asked you
write every single day I would ask you
to ask yourself that question what is my
story what can I do to leave a footprint
to carve my name on the tree and say I
was here I felt something and I matter
how will you affirm your own existence
your agency your creative vitality in a
way that serves not just you but others
and by the way it feels really
good to help other people it's called
the helpers hi neurochemical you get
rewarded for serving others altruism
compassion and empathy gets us off so on
top of everything like it seems that
we're designed to be kind to one another
it's gotta be a sign that we're on the
right path and when you look at all the
ways in which this creativity has
manifested itself right as Terence
Mckenna says human beings are the coral
reef like animal that extrudes
technological material our creativity
has become manifest in the world in the
form of our tools and technologies what
is the man made the human-made world if
not the condensation of human
what is the man-made world if not our
creativity imagination and vitality
turned inside out our smartphones are
extensions of our mind technology is a
scaffolding that extends our thoughts
our reach and our vision not only that
but these tools and technologies have
been advancing exponentially right we've
exceeded our own intuition because we
continue to think that the challenge is
that we have before us are too difficult
to surmount that technology will cause
more problems before it causes or
creates the right solutions but see we
have exceeded our own intuition
technology's actually going faster than
what our very intuition tells us when
you think about change you think about
it linearly when you think about
technological advancement the creative
enterprise of human beings you think
about it as a slow-moving linear dream
but it's not technology changes
exponentially we've unleashed a kind of
divine self-organizing Engineering if
you take 30 linear steps which is how we
think about technological change you get
to 30 if you take 30 exponential steps
which is how technology changes over
time you go to 4 16 by step 30 you're at
a billion and that's why the smartphone
in your pocket today is a million times
cheaper a million times smaller a
thousand times more powerful than what
used to be a 60 million dollar
supercomputer that was half a building
in size 40 years ago in 40 years the
supercomputer was half a building now it
fits in your pocket and the one in your
pockets a thousand times more powerful
why am I telling you this because a
young kid in rural Africa with a
smartphone has better communications
technology than a head of state had 25
years ago I'm telling you this because
according to a 2010 United Nations study
cited by Bill Clinton in a Time magazine
cover story the cell phone was the
greatest invention in history to pull
people out of poverty I'm telling you
this because the tools to make our
dreams come true the tools to change the
world the tools to change ourselves are
now in everybody's hands and as Marshall
McLuhan the
Media philosopher used to say we build
the tools but then the tools
build us that means we extend our
capabilities we redefine our boundaries
we transcend our limits we become
something more than what we were and
this creativity this fire in the belly
that has engendered itself in the form
of marvelous jetliners and computers and
information technologies you know our
capacity to take in material of low
organization put it through the filters
of the mind and extrude space shuttle's
and iPhones this capacity is now spilled
over into our very biological being
genetics and biotechnology is now
allowing us to reprogram our DNA because
it turns out we are made of language we
are linguistic we are alphabetic all the
way down
DNA is code and code that we can
increasingly manipulate we are now
directing our own evolution we have the
capacity to reprogram our genes to turn
off genes that cause cancer to turn on
genes that promote longevity to
alleviate suffering to cure illnesses
all within our grasp and you know what
else is within our grasp human mortality
itself Larry Page the co-founder of
Google recently started calico the
California life extension company a
software company for biology Time
magazine cover story said Google and the
end of death Silicon Valley's next
frontier disease and aging turns out
human creativity has finally exceeded
its own biological limitations and we
are on the cusp of engendering our own
godhood having invented the gods that
Alan Harrington now we can turn into
them Stewart Brand said we are as gods
and might as well get good at it craig
Venter who created the first synthetic
organism was asked by the media do you
worry that you're playing God you know
what he said who's playing
so this
may start with a nodding resignation
with a feeling of hopeless and helpless
9 in the belly but it leads us towards a
teleological directionality a move
towards greater complexity creativity
and organization the technology of the
oil painting was a necessary
prerequisite according to Kevin Kelly
for the marvelous creative expression of
Van Gogh the technology of the musical
instrument was a necessary prerequisite
for the genius of Mozart and Beethoven
to emerge through that what new
technologies what new forms of
creativity will we embody will we
manifest in the world that will act then
as a conduit to new forms of human
rapture radiance and beauty I mean we
have within us the capacity to be
paradise engineers advances in genetics
as I've mentioned artificial
intelligence which continues to advance
exponentially nanotechnology will allow
us to make things buildings that
assemble themselves structures that self
amend I mean look we're on the cusp of
an event horizon some call it the
singularity but perhaps perhaps it is
this event horizon that beckons perhaps
the reason for the fire in our belly
perhaps these existential angst that
afflicts so many of us is a brilliant
glitch in natural selection that has
made us do what we've done and continue
to achieve maybe this was part of the
plan all along I don't know but what I
do know is that it's time to seize the
day we have the tools we have the
capacity we have the creative vitality
to overcome any and all limitations but
we must do it together we must come up
with consensus and we must figure out a
way to thwart the dummies the fear
mongers
the weaponized pneumatics and the filter
bubbles and the self-reinforcing
algorithms that forces into staying in
our cognitive biases and slippage azan
social media or the doom and gloom
messaging of the media enterprise we
must look beyond
the point being we're all on this
journey together we're all on this
search together and in the words of
Walker Percy the search is what anyone
would undertake if they were not soaked
in the everydayness of their own lives
to become aware of the possibility of
the search is to be on to something not
to be on to something is to be in
despair and as David Foster Wallace
wrote the alternative to seizing that
call the alternative is unconsciousness
the default setting the rat-race
the constant gnawing sense of having had
and lost some infinite thing